there's something about a reset routine
a time of starting over and wiping the
Slate clean that is highly encouraging
for most people New Year's brings a sort
of high energy motivation where we set
amazing goals and intentions
but more often than not because these
goals are so far out that it seems we'll
never get there this motivation dwindles
and we often end up forgetting all about
the things that we wanted to accomplish
to begin with
ever since I read the book The 12-week
work year I realized that I am much more
likely to accomplish my goals if I set
short-term intentions and then I don't
have to wait until the next year to get
the excitement of a reset I can inject
these routines quarterly and even
monthly this helps me to embrace the
changing of seasons and phases of my
life rather than trying to rush past
them
so today I will bring you along on my
minimal monthly reset routine
the first step is to organize don't
clean in this step
before I do anything else my first task
is to organize the house I do a deep
clean later
right now I just want to put things
where they go so that I can have a clear
open space to reflect the mental Clarity
that I'm preparing myself for
I've heard that our homes and our
workspaces are a reflection of our mind
and often when we hoard or keep clutter
we're also carrying mental wounds
spiritual emotional baggage such as
fears anxiety frustrations and
addictions
so as I tidy my home I open up myself to
order and create a space that promotes
Tranquility creativity and peace
my next step is to do a monthly review
and set intentions
so in this now cleared up space I then
take the time to review the previous
month and set intentions for the month
ahead
my favorite way to do this is to do free
handwriting about both the past month
and the month ahead
my disappointments the things that I
wish I had done differently the hopes
that I have going forward and the ways
in which I plan to improve and any ideas
that come to my mind
this is not meant to be a task bullet
list or a smart goal plan I share more
about goal setting on my video how to
actually achieve your goals this to me
is a way to mentally free myself from
carrying these thoughts worries and just
ideas in my brain because I've already
dumped them onto a piece of paper I
think of this as a brain dump with a
monthly overview
once I have done this my next step is to
schedule everything well almost
everything this step is easily one of my
most loved hacks for time management and
compassionate productivity and I use the
word compassionate because I am totally
okay with rescheduling something when
life happens but if it's something
that's important to me I'll make sure to
reschedule it rather than drop it off
the list I begin with the most important
slash not so easily rescheduled events
typically my work schedule is decided
for me one month in advance because I
work three 12-hour shifts I start off
the month by placing all of my shifts in
my Google Calendar and then plan
everything else around that scheduling
any doctor's appointments the days that
I'll be serving at church any outings
that I want to go on and finally for the
to-do's that I may otherwise
procrastinate on like taking things to
the consignment shop or getting my oil
changed I schedule those on the days
that I don't work or before work to make
sure that I don't forget about these
items as the month goes on the key is to
make sure that you schedule everything
that you want to make sure it gets done
and if for some reason something happens
and the day comes and you actually can't
do that thing that you planned on doing
don't just delete it or don't just
forget about it for the next day
reschedule it right then and there I
have personally been using Google
Calendar for a while now and I love that
you can color code the tasks that you do
and that I can also see you for example
birthdays or things from my contacts but
you can also use a paper calendar if you
want to and get as fancy as you want
with it I'm just biased towards digital
because it's something that I am able to
see and share with other family members
and if somebody asks me hey can you do
this on next month on a Tuesday I don't
have to mentally remind myself what do I
have to do next month on a Tuesday I can
actually look at my calendar right then
and there and not risk that I might
schedule something when I already had
something planned for that day also
Google Calendar is totally free 99 the
next step is to eat the Frog to do the
thing that you most dread doing up until
this point I had been doing things that
for the most part really didn't require
a whole lot of effort on my part and I
did this intentionally to start me off
on the right foot for the test that I
don't want to do but that I would feel a
whole lot better once I've actually
completed them this for me tends to be
anything paperwork or digital
organization this is things like
scanning or digitizing any important
documents backing up my computer and my
least favorite part of the video making
process decluttering my phone and laptop
of any Clips or files that I need to
delete or back up many of these tasks
often don't take as long as I imagine
but because there's no makeover effect
no before and after like when I tidy my
home I don't find them as rewarding and
I tend to procrastinate a lot and it
ends up making it a lot harder when I
actually go to do them because by then
it's all piled up and I have more to do
so by doing these tasks as early in the
month as possible I eliminate that
feeling of dread throughout the month
freeing me for the activities that I
actually enjoy and it also helps
increase my motivation because I did the
thing that I didn't want to do creating
a sense of momentum for the activities
for the month ahead
my next step is to do a whole house deep
clean
some of you may think that I'm crazy for
saying this but I actually enjoy taking
a full day to deep clean my house
I love the mini makeover Feeling by
seeing the before and after
and because I don't have nearly as many
items in our home as we once had most of
the items are now things that I
genuinely love and enjoy and having less
items also means that it's a lot easier
and quicker to clean making cleaning
much more enjoyable because I am
cleaning the items that I love to use
that I find Value in and that I want to
last for a long time
I usually start off with a good floor
clean making sure to rescue any lost
toys under the couches and toss the dust
bunnies
washing all my linens with eucalyptus
Epsom salt for soft and delicious
smelling sheets
and making sure to get those often
forgot about areas like the sink drains
the fridge the freezer mystery meals
baseboards and Appliance maintenance
like cleaning our coffee machine or
washing machine
after this step is a declutter for me
know how steep clean is complete without
a declutter and you would think that
after years of decluttering there comes
a point when you're done but life
changes your hobbies change things break
or you make mistake purchases
for this reason I have a designated
declutter Basket in the home where I
place any items that I either want to
declutter or that I'm unsure of and that
I want to think about for a bit
I love to go through it after a whole
house deep clean because it's a time
where I'm already going through all the
items in the home anyway giving me the
perfect opportunity to toss any broken
toys or donate any of the items that we
will no longer use
but I do want to warn that while the
declutter basket can definitely be
helpful it can also be very tempting
just to pile items inside and forget
about it so I make sure to schedule a
time when I'm either going to sell these
items or donate them because piling
items into a box is not decluttering
it's rearranging I found a thrift store
near me that donates all profits to
battered women and it tends to be my
go-to but there are many ways to
responsibly get rid of your items such
as donating food to homeless shelters or
Linens to a local animal shelter
whichever way I choose to get rid of the
items I make sure to schedule it so that
it actually gets done my next step is to
do a financial review I review our
finances much more frequently than this
but the first week of every month is
when I fill out and designate our
donation envelopes I love doing this for
many reasons but I find it a good
spiritual practice to start off the
month with a giving mindset
rather than immediately focusing on how
much we want to save or the bills that
we have to pay of course I do keep these
things in mind however and I personally
do so by calculating any unexpected
expenses that fall outside of the budget
for the month so basically what I have
is a working list on my phone of all of
our monthly expenses basically this is
like our budget so every month I have
the things that we have to pay for at
the very top I write out how much money
we have in our accounts how much we have
saved and I also make sure to jot down
any expenses that I expect to make
throughout the month for example I had a
three thousand dollar medical bill that
I thought was going to be much cheaper I
could sit and complain about the Health
Care system which I definitely did but
being proactive and planning for major
expenses like this can help you make
better decisions as the month goes on
and just ease your stress and anxiety
because this way I have a bird's eye
view
these are the resources that I have and
this is how I'm going to allocate them
and last but definitely not least is
education every month I set aside some
time to figure out what books I'm going
to read for the month and it may be a
mixture of physical books as well as
audio books I personally love audiobooks
because they've been of tremendous value
to me I can take mundane tasks like
cleaning my house for example driving to
work I do a lot of driving as a home
nurse and take this time to learn things
to improve my mental spiritual health
and not stay stuck in my old ways of
thinking and my old habits I think that
if we're not moving forward in life
we're moving backwards but we're never
stagnant and I don't know about you but
I have a lot of issues to work on and
books have been of huge huge value in
just helping improve my life two books
that I'm currently loving is why has
nobody told me this before by Dr Julie
Smith and boundaries by Henry Cloud I
love these because I am a chronic people
pleaser and I have issues with setting
boundaries and so these books um I am
loving I'm loving I highly recommend
them the apps that I use are the Hoopla
app which is how I can obtain free
ebooks and audiobooks for my local
library a similar version is Libby you
can check with your local library to see
if they have such an app
but I also use the audible app because
it has a lot of the newer titles that
tend to not be available through the
local library I do have a link for a
free 30-day trial of audible as well as
a free audiobook yours to keep and I'll
leave that link down in the description
box below but definitely check with your
library and see if there's such an app
available and take advantage of those
resources I remember hearing a quote
somewhere I don't remember where I heard
it from that we start dying when we stop
learning and at least my perception is
that if you want to improve your life
you have got to make learning a part of
your natural habit just something that
you normally and naturally do so
audiobooks for me has been of huge value
because it's something that I don't have
to necessarily think about to try to add
into my schedule if I'm already busy
that's all I have for you today I hope
that what I've shared has been helpful
if there's anything that you want to see
in the future please leave it down in
the comments below or send me an email I
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you in the next one bye for now